to evaluate how accessible any app is
you can step through the accessibility
testing checklist some of those steps
will involve changing the accessibility
settings in the Settings app a user will
be able to choose from these options we
have talked back
captions magnification increased font
size and more I want to point out one
item in particular
talkback service blind and low-vision
users can turn on the talkback service
it allows them to navigate around the
device with spoken feedback as they
interact with each UI element on the
screen there are slightly different
gestures for example to select or focus
on an item if it's the first time you
turn it on there'll be a tutorial that
you can step through when the user
navigates to these elements talkback
service will read aloud the content
description provided every UI component
that doesn't have any visible text has a
Content description using talkback or
another accessibility tool from the
checklist open the sunshine app find and
fix at least one accessibility issue in
the app then please share what you did
in the class discussion forum